macquarie capital has been  investing in infrastructure for many  decades now and while this hasn't always  been the case  fiber and digital infrastructure is now  firmly regarded i believe by the  investment community  as core infrastructure seen as as  essential  to any consumer or business as ensuring  you have electricity  gas um gas water etc so  the challenge for the fibre community is  not raising capital that's quite easy to  do  the challenge for the fiber community  now is on delivery it's on execution  we're at a very early stage a lot of  capital has rushed in  and now we need to really deliver on  that business plan  build out those fiber networks to time  to budget  to ensure that the whole of europe has  the fiber connectivity that it so  desperately needs